il y a les plus démunis nous devons les
aider à surmonter ce moment de crise qui
fait peser sur eux des difficultés
accrues
c'est le sens de l'aide exceptionnelle
de solidarité voulue par le président de
la république depuis le début du
confinement
les familles doivent faire face à des
charges supplémentaires qui sont souvent
de nouveaux poids financier pour les
plus fragiles comme les crèches et les
cantines ont fermé elles doivent faire
face à des dépenses supplémentaires pour
les repas leurs dépenses énergétiques
augmentent des nouvelles charges les
charges de trop qui peuvent les
installer dans des situations
dramatiques
nous avons également entendu l'appel des
associations de lutte contre la pauvreté
que je voudrais remercier ici pour leur
travail quotidien
aussi avons nous décidé de verser dès
que possible c'est à dire le 15 mai
prochain
150 euros par ménage au rsa ou à
l'allocation de solidarité spécifique
s'y ajouteront 100 euros supplémentaires
par enfant
nous avons également décidé de verser
100 euros par enfant pour les ménages
qui ne sont pas éligibles au rsa ou à
l'allocation de solidarité spécifique
mais qui sont bénéficiaires des
allocations pour le logement
ce sera automatique sont cocus de
démarches que soient nécessaires je
précise que les bénéficiaires de
l'allocation adulte handicapé qui touche
les aides au logement c'est ado
logements seront aussi concernés
au total ce sont plus de 4 millions de
foyers qui seront bénéficiaires de cette
aide d'urgence
toutes ces mesures de soutien et de
reconnaissance vis d'apprendre la mesure
du choc unique auquel nous sommes tous
ensemble confrontés et auxquelles nous
devons répondre et à accompagner les
français en ces temps de risques et
d'incertitudes
je vais laisser à bruno le maire à
gérald darmanin et à olivier véran le
soin de présenter dans le détail ces
mesures leur calibre al leur impact
je vous remercie